hey youtubers is Charlie so Ben Affleck
Batman dropping a Justice League
Deathstroke bomb on us let's break it
down so if you're wondering what's going
on there there was no sound when he
posted this obviously no explanation
just wants to be cryptic let people have
some fun trying to figure out what the
hell's going on
Deathstroke is definitely going to be in
the DC movies one of my ideas for the
Suicide Squad sequel was to make it a
Deathstroke movie but this actually
looks like they're gonna upgrade it and
he'll appear somewhere in Justice League
and then go on to the Batman solo film
there is a rumor floating around that
he's gonna be the main villain of the
solo film there's no way DC's gonna
confirm that anytime soon but they're
still filming Justice League right now
so like when he turns to set like when
Ben Affleck turns his head to the side
you see a little bit of green screen
there's somewhere on the set of Justice
League so my guess is is that
Deathstroke is just gonna pop up
somewhere they're like you look in the
background of this video you can see the
Batmobile in the plane that they're on
might be Ben Affleck's like floating
Batcave that he's supposed to build for
the film this is when people got to go
to the set of Justice League they were
talking about like a big airplane that
Batman has it's kind of like his
floating Fortress Mobile Batcave that
they used in the film but as for the
Batman's solo film Ben Affleck and Geoff
Johns are still writing it they're
probably a long ways off from shooting
it so I'm not expecting them to say
anything official about that movie for a
long time but you're because a lot of
big stuff is dropping this month I feel
like you know they're in anticipation of
like everybody going back to school they
want to drop some big teasers so if
there was any doubt Deathstroke coming
to the DC movies but the video quality
of this also makes me feel like this
might be for like the Batman Arkham vr
game so I feel like there are a couple
things going on here one Ben Affleck
definitely on the set of Justice League
playing with this two could be Batman VR
but also teasing Deathstroke in the
movies so it makes sense that Warner
Brothers wants to sync up all those
things like Deathstroke is an amazing
character of course they're gonna use
him in the movies but they also got this
big Batman Games is dropping in October
the real question I think is if he's
gonna be the main villain of that Batman
solo film what kind of story are they
gonna do
because Ben Affleck said that they're
not gonna do a comic book story but
it'll be influenced by
comic book stories so most of you are
probably familiar with Deathstroke Teen
Titans stories the Judas contract was
like the famous like the most famous
Teen Titans Deathstroke story where it
was revealed that he was Slade Wilson
previously you'd really only known the
Deathstroke character he was like this
badass guy that never took his mask off
but then he was unmasked in this as
Slade Wilson the father of one of the
people inside the Teen Titans so it's
like oh my god your father is the big
villain we've been fighting the whole
time very much a Darth Vader Star Wars
reveal so I don't think they're gonna do
that for the Batman solo film but
Deathstroke is just like one of those
characters depending on how powerful
they make him in the movies
that could take on the Justice League
combined so he is a really safe bet for
a Batman villain like you know just a
really amazing character that everybody
loves that would be totally badass so
safe bet so I definitely approve of him
in the movies and I feel like what
they'll probably do for like big action
set-pieces is they'll do like the Black
Panther spider-man Civil War stuff where
he's 100% CG in the fight scenes but
then when he's walking around it's like
an actor in a physical suit they kind of
did the same thing in Justice League too
but I feel like Civil War had like more
up-close
daylight shots of them so when Yuri
watch Captain America Civil War like in
the airport scenes where Black Panthers
like being the out of everybody
that's 100% CG they're probably gonna do
the same thing with Deathstroke in the
DC movies just because his moves are so
hardcore it'd be almost impossible for
like a real-life actor to actually do
all that stuff but if you want some
Deathstroke fun in the meantime go back
and already watch like the second half
of arrow season 2 the jacked up on
mirakuru version of Deathstroke that
Manu Bennett played was a lot of fun
like when he was crazy on the drugs let
me know in the comments though what do
you guys think of this and where do you
think we'll see Deathstroke pop up first
in the movies probably just like a small
place in Justice League then going on to
like a much bigger role in a Batman
movie but once he's in the universe he's
fair game for any of the other movies so
I would also expect him to pop up in the
Suicide Squad sequel but if he's gonna
be the main villain of the Batman solo
film I don't think he would also be the
main villain of the Suicide Squad sequel
that'll probably be the Joker like
Suicide Squad will
probably double down on a Harley Quinn
and the Joker because everybody felt
like they cut most of the good Joker
stuff out of the movie but get hype and
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's a $20 Amazon gift card so
what's gonna happen next is there was a
bunch of cool flash stuff for the TV
show that was revealed over the weekend
so I'm gonna do a video for that later
tonight
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch that funny thor
ragnarok trailer again and you can click
here to watch the Civil War bloopers
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight